- What they're doing here is
in response to a New York law
that says that if you're
being sued for defamation,
you can actually mitigate
some of those circumstances
by filing a retraction.
And filing a retraction can help
with punitive damages,
though it won't reduce
the compensatory damages
if you are sued for defamation.
- So, so you-
- We wanted to talk to you
about canceling culture if you will,
we don't want to re-litigate the,
the ah.
- Wait.
- I'm being repressed.
I'm being repressed.
See the violence inherent in the system.
- Do you know what?
They did this because I'm reviewing all
the evidence on Friday
of all the election prob
with these machines.
- And then he just goes right back to it.
- Can I ask our producers?
Can we get out of here please?
I don't want to have to
keep going over this.
- Yeah, they're afraid
because they should be.
- Mike hold on a second.
Everybody hold on a second.
Mike, Mike hold on one second.
- And then the epic walk-off.
Check out my whole video
on the whole defamation suit and subscribe
or I'll see you in court.